l'eau et la boue a envahi la soixantaine
de parcelles de ces jardins ouvriers du
nord d'orléans
les passionnés sont néanmoins au
rendez-vous ce week-end sous la contente
car il ya toujours quelque chose à faire
au potager voilà puis on pourrait
accueillir des des choux de bruxelles
avec les côtes de porc demain cueillir
les légumes d'hiver maître du paillage
en prévision de jeu les tailles et
certains sambre les occupations ne sont
pas aussi nombreuses qu'au printemps
mais elles permettent de se préparer à
la haute saison du jardin ce projet est
quand même dans l'avenir en disant
envoyés vivement le printemps qu'on
puisse venir travailler s'aérer et ce
malgré le contexte actuel de la de
lakovic quoi on risque moins un attrapé
le cléac'h au vide ici que d'aller dans
un supermarché ou au marché cherchait
des légumes les 450 familles qui
bénéficient d'une parcelle autour
d'orléans l'ont bien compris
autant ducobu cultiver son jardin est
une source d' équilibre jamais la
fréquentation de ces potagers n'avait
été aussi importante il faut savoir
qu'on a une population majoritaire des
mines des migrations et donc ils ont bu
c'est une nécessité pour s'alimenter et
on a constaté que desjardins était très
bien que le qui veut cette année
l'association qui gère ces jardins
ouvriers et familiaux en a tiré un
enseignement leur potager peuvent
devenir une partie de la réponse aux
préoccupations de nourriture saine
locales et peu onéreuses sur la
métropole
nous gérons 450 parcelle de jardin pour
comparaison à tour il y avait mis le
jardin donc je pense que on pourrait
encore augmenter ce nombre de jardins on
voit bien que ici beaucoup de gens sont
en appartement et en plus de pouvoir
sortir dans leur jardin avoir accès à
une alimentation
quand même
locales et économique la demande
d'extension de ses jardins sera donc
proposée dans le cadre des assises de la
transition écologique organisée
actuellement par la métropole orléanaise